when a Chinese spy was extradited to the
U.S the FBI got its hands on a
remarkable resource his iPhone
it shed valuable light on how Asia's
largest economy steals top secret
technology Shu yanjun was an agent of
China's Ministry of State security when
he was arrested in Brussels in 2018. how
could the FBI prove it well on his
iPhone was an official form that listed
his job as Deputy division director at
the MSS it might as well have said
profession spy
shoe's main job was stealing defense and
Aviation Innovations from firms such as
General Electric in 2014 for instance a
colleague distracted a British engineer
over a banquet in Nanjing while Shu was
upstairs in his hotel room copying the
content of his laptop Shu said he needs
three hours speeded up came the response
between messages to seemingly
extramarital lovers shoe are Specialists
from China's top Aviation companies what
sort of Intel they needed then set about
cultivating the sources who could
provide it one such Source was a GE
engineer who would ultimately
precipitate his downfall
after being rumbled by the FBI the
engineer turned double agent and offered
to meet Shu at a cafe in Brussels it was
of course a setup on route to that
fateful meeting Shu messaged his wife
that there was a USB stick hidden at
home for which she'd be given the
password was something to happen to him
she responded oh my God don't scare me
like this the next day he was arrested
he now resides in an Ohio jail facing up
to 60 years in prison
[Music]